c'est l'heure de la chronique science
avec renault manuguerra gagné 300
secondes de science alors trois sujets
qu'on sélectionne chaque semaine on aime
tous se raconter des histoires c'est
quelque chose qu'on trouve au coeur de
toutes les cultures et cette semaine il
ya des chercheurs qui a annoncé avoir
découvert ce qui pourrait être la plus
vieille histoire du monde sur le mur
d'une grotte en indonésie renault
bonjour les dessins qui remonteraient à
44 mille ans oui ça c'est extrêmement
vieux sans frais lune ou si c'est pas la
plus vieille peinture préhistorique
qu'on connaît jusqu'à maintenant ou à
ski qui dépeint vraiment une scène où
ici dans ce que si c'est une scène de
chasse des images comme ça des débuts ce
genre de peinture là qu'on voit sur les
cavernes on en a trouvé dans des
centaines d'endroits un peu partout à
travers le monde les sites c'est surtout
en france en espagne les imans je
remonte à vingt ou quarante mille ans
mais ces images-là cette scène de chasse
convenait denaisis d'ailleurs que qu'on
voit à l'écran zing ça a été fait cette
découverte a été faite par des
chercheurs de l'université griffith en
australie dont un québécois qui
s'appelle maxime aubert je travaille là
bas et donc ces images je pourrais 44000
en plus vieille que toutes les autres
qu'on a trouvée jusqu'à maintenant ils
ont les voit et ce qu'on voit les crans
à ccc de pigments couleur rouille
l'envoi une scène de chasse aux oeufs
six personnages six chasseurs qui sont
en train d'essayer de s'en prendre à un
buffle pour les chercheurs cette image
2d jeu le juste son âge est
impressionnant mais il y aussi le fait
que quand on regarde vraiment ce qu'ils
ont montré dans leurs études qu'ils
aient pu quitter pull et publiée dans
nature
ce qu'on regarde vraiment les petits
personnages humains on voit qu'ils sont
pas totalement humains ils ont des
caractéristiques moitié animal moitié
humain certains ont des têtes de
d'oiseaux détail de reptiles ou
différentes autres caractéristiques
comme ça il était créatif prison c'est
les archéologues ce genre de dessin
combiner les archéologues appelle ceux
d'été y entre up et pour les chercheurs
l'idée que ces êtres humains l'oeil à 44
milan fait concevoir des choses qui
n'existaient pas dans la nature
mais si on remet ça dans l'évolution la
culture humaine en général c'est un
concept qui est à la base de plusieurs
religions
donc pour ces chercheurs le fait que ces
dessins la montre que l'art mais aussi
les croyances dans le surnaturel ça
pourrait des choses qui remonte à
beaucoup plus loin dans l'histoire
humaine que ce qu'on croyait jusqu'à
maintenant c'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont
vraiment qu'ils sont vraiment uniques
puis qui marque la tension en ce moment
c'est intéressant
en plus des chercheurs québécois qui
derrière ça entre autres on va quitter
les
cavernes on va aller dans l'espace on
change d'époque gouvernement oui mais là
la nasa a diffusé des images assez
impressionnant oui c'est ils ont testé
ils ont montré des images d'un test ou
est ce qu'ils ont en fait montré les
limites des fusées de leur prochaine
fusée spatiale qu'on appelle la space
launch system ou la sls ça ça va être la
plus puissante fusée jamais créé quant à
va être complété celle qui on voit
qu'ils vont envoyer les prochains
humains sur la lune et plus loin encore
en attendant les ingénieurs sont en
train de vouloir tester sa résistance au
stress en la poussant délibérément à son
point de rupture et c'est ça qu'on va
voir ici à l'école on voit le réservoir
principal la fusée qui vient d'exploser
qu'on veuille comme ça c'est les
chercheurs l'ont ont augmenté
volontairement la pression à l'intérieur
jusqu'à temps que sa cèdent pour voir à
quel point la fusée était capable de
résister jusqu'où on peut aller jusqu'où
pouvait aller et ce qu'ils ont montré
c'est que cette fusée le pouvait
encaisser deux points et six fois plus
de stress et de tension que ce cas va
vivre lors d'un véritable vol donc pour
les chercheurs et les ingénieurs de la
nasa c'est un succès cette explosion la
voilà contre-productif a explosé ces
fusées mais c'est le succès et ça montre
que ben en fait c'est ce qui fait
qu'elle a révélé ensuite au monde le
dernier des cinq étages cette fusée là
kika va être complété que les cinq
étages vont assembler ça va faire une
fusée de 111 mètres de long et les
premiers vols habités vont être en 2
d'ici 2024 c'est ce qui va envoyer entre
autres la prochaine la première sur mars
la première américaine sur la lune le
premier test inhabitée lui devrait se
faire en 2021
et s'il ya beaucoup de gens qui ont
vraiment hâte de le voir parce que ce
qu'on appelle le programme artemis
maintenance a accumulé beaucoup de
retard
le premier vol devrait avoir lieu cette
année au départ dans les plans initiaux
le mét ans en 2021 les frais south a
aussi coûté jusqu'à 9 milliards de
dollars concevoir toute cette fusée le
tout ce programme là donc avec tout ce
temps et cet argent mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont hâte de voir les
résultats et de voir cette fusée de
décoller c'est clair là il y en a aussi
qui ont hâte de voir les prochaines
dimanche parce que j'en ai parlé juste
avant la pause d'un bateau qui flotte
sur des sens oui c'est ça c'est quelque
chose qui se passe dans l'océan dans le
sien pacifique ces images qui date du
mois d'août dernier mais qui sont resté
un mystère jusqu'à maintenant on savait
pas d'où l'on serait pas qu'est ce qui
est en train de se passer d'où ça venait
donc ce qu'on va voir à l'écran semences
est pas un bateau qui est au milieu d'un
grand stationnement
il est au milieu de l'océan pacifique en
ce moment et il est entré donné vie
et au milieu de nerfs de cendres donc
c'est des cdc de la roche qui flotte
c'est sur une étendue de 170 kilomètres
carrés dont on voit le bateau qui avance
ici ça c'est vraiment de la roche
volcanique qui flottent à la surface de
l'eau au milieu de l'océan pacifique
c'est la lave qui viennent aux volcans
sous marins
donc quand quand un volcan sous-marin
être en éruption la lave solidifiée très
rapidement sous l'eau ça va piéger du
gaz à l'intérieur il se fait que la
roche ou être plus légère et souhaite à
flotter donc sur cette masse de roche là
est en train de naviguer vers
l'australie et devrait atteindre la
grande barrière de corail en février
2020 mais jusqu'à maintenant parce qu'on
savait pas si doux avenue était apparu
dans l'océan pacifique on ne savait pas
exactement qu'est ce qui s'était passé
cette semaine les chercheurs ont retracé
le volcan qui était à l'origine de
l'explosion cet cendres là c'est un
volcan au large des eaux dans le qui
vient qui dans le royaume de tonga ça
c'est des îles du pacifique symbole
qu'un que même pas de nom il ya un
numéro de série on l'appelle le volcan f
il est en train de rupture ont envie de
se faire connaître est entré en éruption
que c'est sous dernier et le fait que ça
a pris autant de temps pour trouver
l'origine ce prix original passe quand
même beaucoup de volcans dans la région
mais ça montre à quel point on connaît
peu de choses sur les volcans
sous-marins sont très difficiles à
étudier et nous réserve parfois des
images surprenantes comme cette cendre
qui fait ce serait dommage qu'ils
flottent à la surface sur une aussi
grande et elle sait pression' et je
pense hissel a repris vie terre naviguer
au travers de sa traversée soit y avait
l'impression parfois ces dix avaient
hauteur environ 6 pouces de sang dans
lequel travers ce qu'ils étant très bien
merci
j'avais l'impression que leur bateau est
attendu un brise glace par moment c'est
assez c'est assez impressionnant comme
description confrères et l'abbé merci
beaucoup et nous a fait plaisir
bonne journée